the Palestinian Authority is already
struggling with a financial crisis but
the new Israeli sanctions could only
make conditions worse Israel collects
taxes and custom duties because it
controls the borders on average that
amounts to about 180 million dollars a
month more than half of the Palestinian
authorities budget
under an agreement dating back to the
1990s Israel takes a three percent
commission and is required to transfer
the rest but that's not always the case
the Israeli government has been
deducting amounts unilaterally for
various expenses Palestinians say the
deductions amount to billions of dollars
and are not audited or transparent in
terms of amounts they continue to
increase and it seems to be a trend
where the more reform and more revenues
we have the more deductions they will
have this means that they intend to keep
us constantly breathing underwater
the Israeli finance ministry has told Al
Jazeera the money withheld will go to
the families of victims of attacks
carried out by Palestinians Israeli
courts hold the Palestinian Authority
accountable for a number of attacks
Osama is facing eight years in prison
and a 56 thousand dollar fine in
compensation for a settler he's accused
of trying to kill in 2021.
Settlers steal our lands and streets
it's only normal to resist the occupying
power why would you ask me to compensate
them it's like asking me to compensate a
thief who stole from me
to compound matters International Aid
has shrunk 90 percent since 2013. where
the clearance Revenue to be completely
suspended for an extended period of time
we would certainly see the Palestinian
Authority in a position where it is
unable to meet its Financial
requirements towards the Palestinian
banking sector which is heavily indebted
indebted to work the Palestinian
Authority is the main employer in the
occupied territory and it hasn't been
able to pay staff full salaries for more
than a year
Palestinians say they won't stop
lobbying the United Nations more so now
with the right-wing government in power
in Israel many say they've been in
difficult situations before where Israel
has kept the Palestinian economy on the
verge of collapse for decades always
barely surviving
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank